i think this is a war to shared moment
in british politics it was such a
spectacular result i'm obviously really
delighted for helen morgan our new
liberal democrat mp for north shropshire
but i'm so proud of our party and our
campaigners i think we brought some new
hope to the whole nation and i think
we've shown uh that we can beat the
conservatives anyway we've beaten the
conservatives in two of their safest
seats this year earlier this year in
darkest blue buckminster with
and now in north shropshire so i think
people will be encouraged that boris
johnson and the conservatives can be
held to account and liberal democrats
can do that
well the party is over seemed to be a
pretty effective slogan for you what
kind of things were you hearing on the
doorstep and when did you get the sense
that this could go your way
well i traveled five times to north
shropshire had 10 days campaigning there
so i talked a lot of voters and actually
to start they were really talking about
issues like the health service
long waiting times for ambulances
difficulties to see their gps the rising
costs of living
and they felt the conservatives were
taking them for granted had taken them
for granted for many years and these are
people who've played by the rules who've
always voted conservative and now
they're turning to the liberal democrats
and you know i i think those local
issues must be remembered of course
there were national issues and i'm not
surprised boris johnson after his
shocking peppa big speech and and all
his party gates uh where they've broken
the rules that they've told us to follow
i'm not surprised that he's now losing
uh support of lifelong conservatives and
many of them said to me
many of them said to me they don't just
so sorry to interrupt you there mr davis
just saying the party chairman was
saying yes the voters did give us a
kicking but we full confidence in boris
johnson prime minister and how long do
you think that is going to remain the
status quo
well i think the conservative chairman
should listen a bit more closely to the
people of north shropshire they were
telling me that they don't think boris
johnson is a decent person not a decent
person to lead our country and frankly
i think the people of north shropshire
have sent in a letter of no confidence
in boris johnson to
the conservative 1922 committee uh i i
think conservative mps will be very
alarmed by this result uh because these
were lifelong conservatives dismayed at
boris johnson's lack of decency saying
they don't like him they don't want him
and so you know i felt for a long time i
felt that he's not fit to lead our
country and i think more and more people
now who used to trust boris johnson no
longer do
very good result for you in this
particular constituency mr davey but you
still have relatively few
mps
is this an inflection point do you think
for the liberal democrats after the
coalition which really drastically
damaged your electoral prospects
i think this is a historic moment for
the liberal democrats let's remember we
won a major uh by-election victory
earlier this year
in cheshire amisham in blue
buckinghamshire where we we took a first
brick out of the conservative blue wall
since then we've been selecting amazing
candidates in seats that we're going to
be targeting the next general election
seats from guildford to eastbourne from
cheltenham to wimbledon and now we won
another seat in a former conservative
heartland and now we're going to go on
to the local election so i think the
liberal democrats are on a roll now i
think people like what we say
about a fairer deal for people over the
health service over schools of the cost
of living and people responding very
positively to our message uh they think
that we're in them and the tories are
out of touch
all right i just want to say mr david i
don't know if it's your lighting but i
know you've got covered you don't look
very well how are you feeling uh not
great i'll be honest uh i'm under the
weather but the sun is shining on the
liberal democrats
a dreadful note uh on which on which to
leave it there um but uh thank you very
much indeed for speaking to us this
morning thanks